this week on brian ross investigates
trouble at the peace corps
we sign up for the peace corps
understanding that they're going to be
risks
but
we don't expect the peace corps itself
to place us in danger and it does
hundreds of young volunteers have become
victims of horrible crimes he sexually
assaulted me
and i was in shock legislation signed
into it all by president obama was
supposed to make things better but the
leading congressional sponsor says that
hasn't happened it looks like it's not
much has changed since 2007
and now in an exclusive television
interview the peace corps first victims
advocate comes forward to say why she
left the agency i had taken
my concerns
as far up as i could go within the peace
corps
and nothing was changing nothing was
being done
and this week's winners and losers in
the media see if you agree with the
editors of mediaite and the mayor was
definitely intoxicated from the studios
of the law and crime trial network in
new york city's herald square
this is brian ross investigates
good evening and thanks for joining us
and welcome to our friends on facebook
live i'm brian ross joined as always by
my colleague roger schwartz and rhonda
we begin tonight with trouble at the
peace corps we've reported in the past
about how hundreds of young volunteers
have said the peace corps failed to
protect them or help them when they
became victims of sexual assault in
their posts overseas and despite new
laws and pledges of reforms the problem
seems to persist rhonda
that's right brian an investigation by
usa today found that reports of
aggravated sexual assault and rape
reported by peace corps volunteers
doubled between
2016 to 2019
when the pandemic curbed overseas
postings
of the volunteers who left the service
in 2019 one in three reported some sort
of sexual assault
i'm emma tremblay and i came to talk
today about the peace corps
i was a peace corps volunteer in ecuador
from 2018 to 2019. it was wonderful
it was it was amazing
i had
fabulous host families i had
amazing students at my school i really
knew
all of the people in my little town and
they knew me and it was pretty great
so what went wrong
what didn't go wrong
emma tremley became the victim of a
sexual assault in ecuador and she says a
victim of a peace corps that fails to
protect its young volunteers
we sign up for the peace corps
understanding that there are going to be
risks
but
we don't expect the peace corps itself
to place us in danger and it does
peace corps volunteers have long been
seen as america's ambassadors to the
world an enduring legacy of its founder
president john f kennedy there can be no
greater service to our country
and no source of pride more real
to be a member of the peace corps of the
united states
but 12 years ago an abc news story
exposed how the peace corps had failed
to protect volunteer kate poozie who was
murdered after she reported the sexual
abuse of young girls in the african
village where she was posted
we are grieving because kate is dead
but we are grieving because kate was
murdered
and the abc news story further revealed
that hundreds of volunteers had been
sexually assaulted with peace corps
administrators trying to cover it up and
put the blame on the young women i had
to list
all the things that i had done wrong
to cause this to happen to me and
all the things that i would do
differently when i returned to prevent
it from happening again the abc news
story led to outrage in congress and
legislation to better protect volunteers
signed into law by president barack
obama with kate pusey's parents and
brother invited to attend
that was 2011.
it seems like nothing has changed
the peace corps is
actively placing us in harm's way
in ways that it doesn't have to often in
violation of its own rules and protocols
for emma trembly it involved the doctor
she was sent to by the peace corps in
keto ecuador
the way that peace corps works
you are not allowed to choose your
medical provider
so
i went through with the appointment
and he sexually assaulted me
and i was in shock and i
i almost couldn't believe that this had
happened to me
at the hands of a doctor that the peace
corps sent me to i just couldn't believe
it just minutes after the appointment
was another volunteer
who told me that she had also seen this
doctor and that he had also been
inappropriate towards her she had
alerted the peace corps medical officers
that they had gone with her and that
they had found his behavior
inappropriate
and they just didn't tell me any of this
they sent me into him alone
knowing knowing
knowing full well
exactly who this man was
yeah
it was incredibly awful and it was also
so awful that i just stopped feeling
anything at all
and i realized
that
if this doctor had done this to me he
could do it to other volunteers too
and that was where i drew the line so i
contacted the peace corps
i told them that i needed to talk to
them
and i reported the assaults over the
phone safety and security told me that
this was a case that he said she said
and so my case would never go anywhere
in the ecuadorian legal system
emma was sent back to the u.s on medical
leave for 40 days when i got back from
my medical evacuation i asked the
country director
what steps he had taken and he didn't
remember why i had been medically
evacuated
so that really broke
my faith that they had done anything to
make sure that this never happened again
so my complaint resulted in the peace
corps not sending any more volunteers to
him but
that shouldn't have been where that line
was drawn
i
at least one other volunteer had
complained before me that is where the
line should have been drawn
emma had watched the abc news report on
kate poozie before signing up as a peace
corps volunteer
it's funny looking back now but yeah
i really believed
it was the peace corps i really believed
that surely the peace corps once this
problem had been pointed out to them
would fix the problem
the brave women who have come forward
have shown us that the peace corps has
not always been sufficiently responsive
compassionate or sensitive to victims of
crime and their families
rest assured that the kind this type of
thing of blaming the victim will not
continue in the peace corps today i
believe they would fix it and and i was
wrong so did you finish your tour in
ecuador i did not i was medically
separated at the end of 17 months
and now emma has made it her mission
using social media to once again get the
peace corps to recognize and fix its
problems
what i heard from people
was eerily similar to the things that i
experienced and these people were so
brave and so strong and so smart
and the peace corps was treating them
like disposable
like they were nothing
and i
i was so furious because it wasn't just
me and i wasn't crazy
and i i was right that the peace corps
simply did not care about our well-being
as human beings they they didn't care
among those who responded was former
peace corps volunteer kat freeman who
served in the philippines where she says
she was raped by another volunteer
did you report it no i did not report it
to the peace corps what did you fear
would happen if you did report it
my main fear was that i would be pretty
much forced to end my service and return
back home and she says given other
incidents she feared she would be blamed
for what happened if something happens
to you it's your fault like why did you
dress that way why did you go out that
way why did you drink that much why did
you say hello to this person you know it
could be anything
do you suppose there are others who are
in your shoes who've had assaults and
have decided not to report it oh i
yeah
there's probably hundreds on hundreds on
hundreds there are about 80 posts with
different people's stories
um
and i have
dozens more
who
are waiting for me to have enough time
to actually publish them
emma says the peace corps has demanded
she take down her site with its peace
corps logo so i got rid of the peace
corps logo but i kept the name because i
wanted people to be able to find me
and since then and since then they
haven't actually sued me which is a
relief because i am a law student and i
have the bar to pass
but it's been
it's been scary um
i don't like being threatened so are you
glad you've taken this stand
glad would be a strong word um
there are a lot of different ways of
dealing with
trauma and
dealing with the trauma of what the
doctor did was one thing but dealing
with the trauma of what the peace corps
did is an entirely separate thing and
this is the only way that i saw to deal
with that is to make sure that it didn't
happen to anyone again that's what i
wanted from the very beginning
when we come back we'll hear from the
first person appointed to be a victims
advocate at the peace corps and why she
lost her job you're watching brian ross
investigates the law and crime trial
network
the peace corps says it has made and
continues to make progress in helping
volunteers who have become victims of
sexual assault but we're about to hear
from two people who say that is simply
not true
i was hired as their first ever victim
advocate and then from there i was moved
up to the director of the office of
victim advocacy which was a new office
so that must have been exciting
it was very exciting and when did it
start to go bad it was
a struggle from the start kelly green
says that she soon began to hear the
same complaints that the women who
appeared in the abc news story years
earlier made about being blamed
themselves for becoming a victim they
were blamed because they were um
walking
alone out of their sight to go get
transportation
um when you're supposed to always have
somebody with you um
that
they were drinking it just always felt
like it was like a deflection so that
the peace corps wouldn't have to take
responsibility that was one of the
things that i always struggled with when
i was at the peace corps
was
trying to help the peace corps see
that you're never going to prevent
sexual assault 100
but what you have 100 control over
is how you respond
and
that is where the peace corps should
focus is how they respond the peace
corps has more than seven thousand
volunteers worldwide but only four
victim advocates when green worked there
is four enough
i would say that the peace corps could
probably do with more
more victim advocates some of them are
18 hours ahead 12-hour you know always
trying to figure out
when we're gonna make those calls happen
so you have
some staff at headquarters that are
working around the clock basically so as
you're pushing for change and
improvements did you start to get pushed
back
i received pushback pretty immediately
but i wasn't surprised by it i
anticipated it i would have been
surprised if i didn't get pushback and
that's because people you know people
just don't like to change
frustrated with the resistance at
headquarters green decided to raise the
stakes i had taken
my concerns
as far up as i could go within the peace
corps
and nothing was changing nothing was
being done i filed a whistleblower
complaint
with the office of special counsel
and that was because i was seeing
the peace corps not
fulfilling
the work that congress had tasked them
to do
it's a very big step to do that it was
not something that i did lightly
but
being the victim advocate that i am
holding the beliefs that i do about
survivors
if i was going to continue in the field
of
victim advocacy
i wouldn't have been able to live with
myself if i hadn't have tried to make
additional changes
once they had you know it had become
very clear to me that it was done the
other reason that i felt really
compelled to file the whistleblower
complaint
was something very unexpected
i never expected to fall in love with
the peace corps volunteers the way that
i did
i've never
worked with a group of individuals
that are
so
focused on what they're doing
that have such
strong ideals
what was the reaction to the
whistleblower complaint
um i was
i was pretty much pushed out of the
agency
so you were the person hired
as a result of the cape towson law
and you had to leave you had to file it
with the ball or complaint because the
peace corps wasn't doing what they said
they were going to do is that fair to
say yes that's fair to say
and you're no longer there
no
and we're joined now by former
congressman ted poe who while in
congress became the champion of peace
corps volunteers helping to push through
the kate pussy law into legislation
getting it signed at the white house and
helping to pass other legislation to
protect the volunteers congressman thank
you for being here we continue to hear
the same complaints though that we heard
10 years ago
you're right brian and it's very
disturbing
that
we we thought we had this issue fixed to
protect
our peace corps volunteers our
greatest ambassadors for america
overseas and it looks like it's not much
has changed since 2007.
why is that do you think
i don't know the answer except
the results are
not changed
volunteers are still uh
apparently being assaulted
some say one in three
have been assaulted since uh
the changes in the law
not enough information i think is being
given to the peace corps volunteers
about their service in the particular
country and what to expect
their medical needs are being hindered
and when they return from the peace
corps service and their departure from
the peace corps
and it
the peace corps volunteers are
frustrated and rightfully so
but they keep signing up keep wanting to
volunteer uh and be
those uh ambassadors for america
overseas
we've just heard from the woman who was
the first victims advocate at the peace
corps who is now she says been pushed
out after she filed a whistleblower
complaint saying the peace corps wasn't
doing what congress intended to do
well that's unfortunate and that's the
whole purpose of the whistleblower act
is to protect people like her so they
can tell what's going on in a government
agency and not suffer consequences for
it so whoever made the decision to
terminate her
based upon the fact that she's telling
what's going on behind closed doors so
to speak
that person should be held accountable
and maybe lose their position but we we
want peace corps volunteers to come
forward and tell us what's going on they
are the ones that are doing the work
they're in cities and countries that
most americans never heard of much less
would ever go to
and they're working and very you know
rough conditions but they want to to
help people and that's what they're
doing and we should listen to what they
say because they know what the answers
are and the problems to their service
overseas
all right congressman ted poe thank you
so much for being with us here at this
eve
thank you brian
the peace corps did not respond to our
repeated request for someone from the
agency to come on our program
last month the organization's victim
advocate did address an online meeting
of former volunteers and claimed the
peace corps is aware there's a problem
i think that sometimes we have to
balance being a federal agency with
actually being able to support survivors
and volunteers the way they want to be
supported i would ask for you know some
grace in terms of time we know that
certain things are kind of like a
dinosaur that you're trying to turn over
right things have been around for a long
time but the the actions are there the
willingness is there the intention is
there um and so i just kind of want to
leave that on the table don't think that
we're not listening because we are and
and like i say you know our our
intention is to continue
to get better and not just leave this as
a one-and-done type thing
so more than a decade after the issue
was first identified the peace corps
says it still needs more time to figure
out how to deal with its volunteers who
have been sexually assaulted
up next this week's winners and losers
in the media
see if you agree with the choices made
by the editors of mediaite you're
watching brian ross investigates on the
law on crime trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media as chosen by the
editors of meteorites and we're joined
by aidan mclaughlin who is the
editor-in-chief of midiite which like
the law and crime network is part of the
dan abrams media group and aiden you've
chosen as a winner this week fox news
correspondent brian yates for his report
at a positive report on a transgender
teen
i'd rather have a living son than a dead
daughter i guarantee that if we had
pushed back and
done what a lot of parents do
i don't think that we would have
either one of the kids that you see
before you here today
so aidan how did that report go over at
fox news well i can tell you how it went
over from my perspective my jaw dropped
when i saw this on fox it was a lengthy
um
very interesting very
thorough report on this trans teen
and how his family has supported him um
and it aired on fox news on a daytime
program on the network which tends to be
a little bit more newsy fair as you know
brian fox news opinion um has spent uh
much of its airtime attacking the trans
community so to see this on daytime at
fox news was a really shocking thing uh
to witness um uh courtesy of this
reporter brian yennis who's been a great
correspondent for fox news for years um
it was a fantastic report really well
done um and you know very empathetic to
what was going on uh we haven't heard a
peep on fox news from fox news opinion
criticizing this report um but it
certainly caused outrage uh outside of
the network from plenty of guests that
appear on the network frequently
particularly the ones that are a little
bit more culture war-minded who have
panned fox and called for the firing of
brian yennis over this report and for
this week's loser in the media former
new york mayor rudy giuliani the trump
lawyer identified in the hearings by the
january 6 committee as going to the
white house on election night
intoxicated aiden
was there anyone in that conversation
who in your observation had had too much
to drink
uh like mayor giuliani
and the mayor was definitely intoxicated
but i did not um
know that his level of talk intoxication
when he spoke
uh with the president for example
well what is a surprise eh
not so much a surprise these rumors have
been circulating for years but the fact
that rudy giuliani was repeatedly
accused of being drunk on election night
and fueling trump's claims of a stolen
election while being intoxicated made it
certainly a big story it's also one that
he's denying rudy giuliani said he only
drank diet coke only drink diet coke
they identified him as being intoxicated
at the white house aiden
that's true yes so i think you know one
one side of the the coin is lying there
um i think given rudy's track record
it's not hard to tell who all right and
thanks so much that's our program
tonight thanks for joining us we'll be
back again here next week on the law and
crime trial network
[Applause]
you